it's a unique show because you're
talking on this program about moral
issues
yeah ethics philosophy how to be a good
person what does it really mean has the
fact that you're all working on this
show now and you're dealing with these
issues has it changed you as people have
you changed at all I think I've become
mildly more empathetic that's a thing
that I would say like were you not
empathetic beforehand
no I'm English I'm a cold dead [ __ ]
touching my shoulder by the way no no no
that's all good yeah I think now when I
meet irritating people I start to look
back inside of them as to why they're so
irritating yeah what about you because
is this something that's changed you at
all have you thought about these issues
my rule before I was on the show was
very simple it was just don't be a dick
and I find that after three years on the
show what I've discovered is it's the
same rule don't be a dick I wish I had I
wish now I wish I had talked to you a
long time have you guys changed at all
do you think just thinking about this
stuff I recycle
so you're saying you didn't recycle
before but because you're playing a
character who's struggling with moral
issues you now recycle yeah what did you
what did you recycle you actually have
to recycle properly and put a waste in a
proper and thanks to this show I have
made my contribution like an L a website
that tells you how to recycle you can do
with pain no plastic DVD batteries take
them - I think Lowe's has a place you
can drop it what are we talking this is
stuff you throw out of your car when
you're speeding